you
robots on the road are one of the most
transformative emerging technologies on
the planet many of us already have
elements of robotic autonomy built into
our cars and we've have had for years
that's right
your car is a robot creating robotic
cars involves incredible challenges
chief among them is this trade-off speed
versus safety as drivers we know this
trade-off firsthand nothing is more
frustrating than being in a traffic jam
that slows us down and nothing is more
scary than being in an ice storm and
losing control of your vehicle
drive safely slow down but if you slow
down you take longer to reach your
destination to enhance both speed and
safety at the same time is the goal of
the modern automotive industry nearly
every manufacturer has already embedded
robotic elements into your car to assist
you
let's take cruise control that's
automatic speed control and it's a
robotic system because it involves
sensor guided movements you let your car
take over the gas pedal allow it to
adjust the throttle keep your speed
steady as you travel up and down hills
now interestingly automatic speed
control was invented in 1788 by James
Watt and Matthew Boulton four steam
engines as a mechanical controller
called a governor it was available as a
working technology almost from the
moment that cars were invented in the
late 1800s but it took until 1958 for
the first commercially available speed
control in a car where it was initially
called an autopilot cruise control is an
example of what works by negative
feedback control now the word feedback
tells us that a sensor is feeding
information about the real world back
into the system for cruise control the
sensor is the speedometer the controller
compares the actual speed to the desired
speed and the difference between those
two is called an error any system that
uses negative feedback control is
self-regulating and embodies the kind of
self-control we see in autonomous robots
the mo of the automobile industry
has been to add one-by-one different
autonomous systems to vehicles in
response to cruise controls lack of
braking in 1995 Mitsubishi introduced a
laser based adaptive cruise control and
the idea behind the adaptive cruise
control which goes by a variety of
different trades name trade names is
what in robotics we call object
avoidance don't hit the object the car
in front of you most adaptive cruise
control systems use radar as their
primary sensor radar is an active sensor
system an emitter sends out radio waves
at a particular frequency and then a
receiver collects the echo the return of
that signal and using radar you can
measure the distance from you to the
nearest object you can also tell the
relative speed of that object whether
it's heading away from you or towards
you and with adaptive cruise control you
set a target speed like good
old-fashioned cruise control but you
don't hit the vehicle in front of you
because of that object avoidance
function you end up following a set
distance behind the vehicle in front of
you and that distance is adjusted based
on the speed you're traveling now to
avoid collisions you need to add an
actuator to your toolkit in addition to
throttle control you need control the
brakes you'll often find emergency
braking sold as a feature on cars and it
really is a part of the whole object
avoidance system even though adaptive
cruise control is meant for the
high-speed movements of freeway driving
some companies like Bosch have a related
system called stop and go that is built
for slow speeds in heavy traffic stop
and go will bring the car to a complete
standstill if needed and then initiate
movement when the car in front moves and
this makes traffic jams far less
frustrating right if you're behind the
wheel so what would we like to add next
in terms of partial autonomy one common
cause of accidents is when you change
lanes and you don't see another car in
your blind spot Bosch offers side view
Assist using four ultrasonic sensors two
on each side of the car the side view
assist signals the driver when an object
is detected in the blind spot in cases
where the car is simply drifting out of
the lane like when the driver is sleepy
some companies offer lane departure
warning to signal the driver and lane
keeping assist to actually take over the
steering video is a common sensor for
lane keeping since most paved roads have
clear lines that mark the road edges of
the road many simple robots do the
equivalent of autonomous lane keeping by
following lines let's do this with
Sparky the robot from arc buttocks
Sparky has three IR sensors on the
bottom and up front here now these are
active sensors with an emitter and a
receiver the emitter pulses an IR signal
that is then reflected off nearby
objects the intensity of the signal
received by the detector can tell the
distance of the object to use these
sensors in line following the trick is
to take advantage of the fact that
different colors positioned at the same
distance have different IR reflectivity
z' so if we put a white line as we've
done here down on this dark surface we
hope that Sparky can detect that
difference and so I've just turned
Sparky on let's see what's going to
happen here and Sparky is going to take
off right now so we'll see if there's
any change in movement yes Sparky has
detected the line it's turning towards
the line here and as it moves along you
can see that it Wiggles makes little
adjustments as it moves along and I got
to keep it from going off here the end
we've just seen line following so what's
cool about this is what's happening is
that the computer code in Sparky is
coordinating the three sensor signals
with its motor movements and commanding
that Sparky turn in the direction of the
sensor that first detects a weaker
signal once all three signals detect
that weaker signal then the trick is to
move in the direction opposite to the
sensor that detects a strong signal from
the white background now this is not how
cars are either keeping to their lane or
navigating longer distances but line
following illustrates two principles of
robotics first we can use sensors to
detect regular features of the world
that allow for local navigation and
second we can modify the environment
help vehicles stay the course in fact we
already have lane markers on the side of
the road and as we just saw with lane
keeping some vision systems in cars make
use of these regularities in the world
the regular position of objects in the
world can likewise serve as information
that a robotic cars can sense and use
take parking Park Assist
can sense other cars and be used when
you want the car to park itself the same
sensors that are used for sideview can
help detect the open parking spot and
then commands are issued to the steering
and gas to maneuver the car carefully
into position now because twice the
number of accidents happen at night
compared to the daytime one of the most
exciting driver assist features is
enhanced night vision this system works
by combining infrared light and video
analysis IR emitters up front in the car
send out signals that are read by the IR
video camera a special screen on the
dashboard shows the scene ahead using
software that also recognizes
pedestrians the night vision system can
brightly illuminate so that they can be
seen and avoided with the exception of
old-fashioned cruise control all of
these behaviors rely on vision or a
sensory capability that functions like
vision such as radar or infrared imaging
engineer Ernst dikmen's
was among the first to build a robust
working vision system for robotic cars
beginning in the 1970s dikmen's realized
that trying to make sense of a visual
scene which was complicated right in
itself was complicated by the fact that
we create all kinds of flow as we move
you can get a sense of visual flow if
you just walk forward and pay attention
to the whole field of view that's
expanding around you the flow of the
visual field is what I experienced as
the sides of my world stream past me the
corollary of visual flow is that the one
object I'm heading towards most directly
does not flow past me but it stays put
so dikmen's recognized when he was
building this vision system the speed
safety trade-off
and he and his team were working at a
time when computers weren't very fast
yet here was all this self-generated
motion and motion of other objects that
had to be sensed disentangled and
computed so his approach was to have the
computer use a model of its motion and
the motion of other objects now here's
the great thing
since motion follows the laws of physics
the robots model can easily build a set
of reasonable expectations about how the
world is going to behave
you can't break the laws of physics so
the trick then is to use your attention
to relate different frames of the visual
fields one another over time to identify
new objects track them and then predict
where they'll be next corrections to the
visual inputs were made using inertial
sensors for velocity and acceleration in
1986 dikmen's and his team built a fully
autonomous robot car the drove in tests
on empty streets in Germany with
partition participation from the
automobile industry by 1995 vehicles
equipped with dikmen's dynamic vision
system were traveling safely for up to a
thousand miles at a time at speeds as
high as a hundred miles per hour on
public highways while dynamic vision
solves many of the immediate problems of
autonomous driving it was not meant to
solve the longer-term problems of
driving from point A to point B so
combining navigation with autonomous
driving and robotic cars was the primary
challenge put forward in 2004 by the
Defense Advanced Research Projects
Agency of the US Department of Defense
which is commonly known as DARPA DARPA
ran a robotic challenge that they called
the DARPA Grand Challenge the DARPA
challenge was for fully autonomous
robotic ground vehicles to succeed a
robot had to travel 150 miles off an on
road between Las Vegas and Los Angeles
now DARPA had this requirement quote
entries must be unmanned autonomous
ground vehicles capable of completing
the entire route without external
communication or human control end quote
what made the DARPA Grand Challenge more
difficult than the work already done by
dikmen's team was that most
that driving was actually offroad no
more lane markers few regularities no
signs no cars to follow off-road is less
structured than on-road darpa defined
the route using a series of GPS
waypoints waypoints and navigation are
any intermediate places on the map that
you have to hit they're the dots you
connect create the path of your journey
now the off-road portions included
mountain passes strewn with rocks and
flat dry lake areas roads would include
some bridges and underpasses GPS
waypoints were provided to teams only a
short time before the race began so the
robots had to be able to quickly read
and plan out a course at first glance
the Grand Challenge of 2004 was a
failure a complete failure even though
15 robots started
not a single robotic vehicle finished
150 mile course some like team and
esko's David were turned turtle by the
local challenges of the terrain and it
was worse than that even the best
vehicle went only seven miles before it
went off course and got stuck on an
obstacle that was a modified Hummer
called sandstorm built and fielded by
red team robot racing from Carnegie
Mellon University but robot assists can
always learn from mistakes we often fail
our way to success so what did we learn
some vehicles were able to navigate to
the GPS waypoints but those robots
tended to do a poor job detecting
objects along the path other vehicles
were better at sensing those objects but
they weren't good at navigating to the
waypoints so it was clear that a
short-range system like dikmen's dynamic
vision needed to be combined with a
longer range navigational system now to
DARP his credit instead of folding up
their tent and running they decided to
hold a similar Grand Challenge at the
next year 2005 given all that had been
learned in 2004 this turned out to be a
brilliant decision in 2005 23 robots
started the 132 mile completely off road
course in the desert of Nevada five
robotic vehicles finished the entire
course because of this huge and positive
turnaround
many consider the DARPA challenge of
2005 to be a watershed moment in
robotics perhaps the most revealing
result in 2005 was that the winning
robot Stanley a modified VW Touareg
hadn't even competed the year before
Stanley was the brainchild of the
Stanford Racing team which was led by
Sebastian Thrun then director of the
Stanford artificial intelligence
laboratory abbreviated as sale so how
did Stanley's team do it here's their
approach in a nutshell treat autonomous
navigation as a software problem the
strategy of the Stanford Racing team was
that all the failures of 2004 could be
solved by building a better control
architecture DARPA had already told
everyone that a stock four-wheel drive
pickup truck could be physically capable
of traversing the entire course so no
need to redesign the body in term of
sensors they used three types for
short-term navigation
staying on the path and avoiding objects
radar was the longer distance system
we've talked about how radar is used for
adaptive cruise control so it's good for
keeping track of other vehicles and is
insensitive to things like shadows that
can throw off a video system for finer
resolution at short distances Stanley
used lidar s which can handle
resolutions down to one centimeter at
distances of up to 25 meters the word
lidar comes from a smooshing of light
and radar the light of a lidar is laser
light which the sensor shines out into
the world and then read the radar like
rebound of that light to measure
distance Stanley used an array of five
lidar mounted on its roof the
second-place robot sandstorm used both
radar and lidar - and the third sensor
system that Stanley used was a video
camera for optical vision that could
sense out past the range of the lidar
but closer than the radar three
different navigational sensor systems
were used because each involves
different trade-offs between range and
accuracy the lidar system provided good
resolution out to about 25 meters the
camera sees farther and is able to
collect more data than an individual
laser the radar senses out too
200 meters but it provides sparser
information about small features and
either the camera or the laser for
long-term long-range navigation Stanley
used a GPS and a compass Stanley also
had an initial measurement unit with
accelerometers akin to those the
dikmen's team had pioneered for road
vehicles and gyroscopes that help
Stanley know when it has turned and if
it's tilting dangerously odometer
sensors also kept track of the number of
rotations of Stanley's wheels to help it
estimate position on the path their
software controller consisted of three
separate modules one a data acquisition
module two a planning module and three a
world model module so this was a hundred
thousand lines of code running on a 1.6
gigahertz Pentium M based computers
which by the way they had six of them in
the trunk
Stanley's controller was innovative for
two reasons first the controller took
into account that all the information
from the sensors about the world and
about the model and it also took it into
account information about the actuators
and all of that information contained
uncertainty so that was the big idea
right getting uncertainty so they
modelled that uncertainty explicitly
second that controller was built to be
teachable and it was extensively trained
by humans during hundreds of hours of
off-road work the idea of modeling
uncertainty has helped create a new
subfield in robotics called
probabilistic robotics one of the things
that is certain about sensors is that
they are uncertain they provide
imperfect information for example let's
say that we're using a camera to detect
edges of the road for lane keeping and
remember cameras are very good at
finding edges because most of the time
edges in the world create sharp
contrasts of light and it's that
contrast line that video cameras love to
see and sense very well but one problem
for a robot is that sometimes high
contrast lines can come from the border
of a shadow they might not be physical
edges at all in other words now you and
I know because of our spear
audience that we needn't be afraid of
our own shadow but robotic light sensors
cannot always tell the difference for
our robots we have to understand how and
when shadows occur and build that
knowledge into our uncertainty about the
information coming from the camera
since radar is sending out radio waves
and reading the reflections radar isn't
fooled by shadows the controller's world
module can then combine this information
from multiple sensors to make a
probabilistic guess about whether the
edge in the camera is an actual edge or
a shadow if it's a real edge then a
quick change in plan needs to be enacted
if not carry on in the dynamic ongoing
process of collecting sensor information
and creating plans and signals for the
actuators each of the controllers
modules does a different job the job of
data acquisition is to collect and then
convert the raw data from the sensors
into the first approximation of
meaningful information for example raw
data from the five lidar s is just a
blur of numbers what do they mean
well answering that question involves
using all five sensors to create a 3d
model of the road ahead searching that
3d model for specific patterns rapidly
and then reporting the patterns to the
planning module the planning module in
turn collects data continuously from all
the sensor systems adjudicates
differences in sensor opinions based on
the probabilities derived from using and
pairing those sensors like we just
talked about and then plots a safe
course to the next Waypoint
because Stanley is in constant motion
both data acquisition and path planning
have to happen continuously and very
rapidly and it's the third model module
the world model that knows how to drive
safely
for robots operating off-road the world
model relies on a map that Stanley has
created in real time just in time as it
drives for example if a turn has to be
made the world model understands how
Stanley handles under the conditions at
hand and then adjust speed and steering
so that Stanley drives under control
this map of
ditions just in front of Stanley is
called the drivability map the
drivability map is linked to a global
reference frame through GPS but then
Stanley's position on it is plotted what
is also plotted on the probabilistic
guesses of where it's safe to drive and
that's drivability by classifying
different parts of the road or terrain
ahead as safe dangerous or don't know
unknown this information can be used by
the planning module to chart a safe
course and speed the way to the next
waypoint so when we look at these
drivability maps the Purple Line
extending out of Stanley's nose is the
best path that the planner has plotted
so the shaded purple area on one of
these maps represents a whole host of
other possible paths now in practice
Stanley had to be taught how to drive
training Stanley is an example of what
we call machine learning what and how
Stanley learned reminds me a lot about
drivers education the goal of drivers
education is to learn to drive safely
right so Stanley is looking ahead and
trying to answer this question as it
drives
is it safe to drive in this area so in
the training phase Stanley has only two
questions two ways to answer that
question yes or no and here's where our
human teacher comes in the driver
education the human drives while Stanley
is on and observes and works on
answering the question about drivability
the human is deciding to drive only
where he thinks the train is drivable
so if Stanley agrees that the path ahead
is drivable then the decision-making
process that Stanley used to make that
decision is rewarded no reward is given
if the human and Stanley disagree for
Stanley the reward is a mathematical
treat increased probability so the next
time that Stanley encounters a similar
pattern of sensor readings then the
probability increases that will classify
the area head as drivable Stanley learns
so now you understand how the Stanford
Racing team was able to treat the
autonomous navigation of a vehicle in
the desert as a software problem
the design of the three module
controller combined with estimating
uncertainty and machine learning were
the keys to the game the loud Stanley to
finish the 132 mile off-road course and
win the race throne and many members of
the Stanford racing team took what they
had learned with Stanley to Google to
build the Google driverless car now
nearly all automobile manufacturers have
begun work on autonomous driving less
cars and they've been helped immensely
by components manufacturers like Bosch
who are making robotic systems that can
be deployed on any vehicle like Google
Bosh's driverless system uses lidar
video and radar to create a dynamic map
of the world part of the technology
transferred from Stanley to the Google
driverless car was this drivability map
Google's testing engineers would ride in
the passenger seat essentially looking
at the Google cars version of Stanley's
drivability map now one of the benefit
of driving on roads as opposed to
off-road is that roads offer more
regularities in the world and more
structure from lines to signs and curbs
google has also mapped the roads so the
robotic car doesn't have to start from
scratch the way Stanley had to in the
desert
what's more challenging though what
makes the world of roads more
unstructured is that in suburban and
urban settings roads can be packed with
a regular traffic not only cars and
trucks of all shapes stopping and
starting and unexpected times and places
but dogs pedestrians skateboarders
bicyclists and their positions are
constantly changing States in the United
States began to offer driverless cars
the right to operate in 2012 and testing
began in the United Kingdom Singapore
and other countries one of the great
things about these vehicular robots is
that this technology can be applied to
trains trucks and buses as well so the
potential here is to completely overhaul
our transportation networks that carry
people and goods for all vehicles an
immediate benefit that we see even with
driver assist functions
a semi-autonomous vehicle is safety
while the number of deaths from
automobile accidents continues to trend
downward as we've added safety features
like seatbelts airbags and anti-lock
brakes tens of thousands of people still
die every year from vehicle related
accidents millions more are injured the
promise of driverless cars trucks and
buses with even more automation is that
they would reduce further those deaths
and injuries and in 2014 the United
Nations Convention on road traffic was
rewritten to allow self-driving cars as
long as quote the system can be
overwritten or switched off by the
driver but what about cases where some
sort of collision remains unavoidable
for those cases rules about how to
function in a collision can also be
programmed into the world model of the
vehicle for example imagine you're being
driven autonomously in a small car on
the freeway
using its radar your robotic car detects
that the tractor-trailer truck just in
front of you is losing control and
predicts using laws of physics right
that collision is imminent and
unavoidable your car runs an accident
model in its planning module and
determines that you sitting in the front
seat are likely to be severely injured
unless action is taken so your car runs
several different plans to ascertain
which course of action is most likely to
reduce your injury it selects the plan
that initiates a 180 degree spin of your
car so that the rear end of your car
collides first with the trailer giving
you five more feet of distance between
the impact point and the collapsing
frame of the vehicle you're injured but
to a lesser degree than what would have
happened had you not had that action
taken in addition to safety driverless
cars could increase the independence and
mobility of people who for a variety of
reasons are unable to drive a car
themselves for example as we age what
often makes assisted-living imperative
is reduced mobility not being able to
get to the grocery store or to a
doctor's appointment one of the
unexpected consequences of having
driverless cars is that we'll be able to
put many more cars on the road as well
by some estimates only 5% of a crowded
road is occupied by vehicles lanes are
much wider than the width of the
vehicles and following distances are
kept larger than physically required to
compensate for the slow reaction time of
human drivers if you take a defensive
driving course the first thing that they
tell you is keep a safe following
distance a Columbia study from 2012
found that each vehicle with robotic
sensing capabilities can contribute to a
steady increase in the capacity of a
highway to allow more vehicles on it
communication among robotic vehicles is
ultimately expected to be even more
powerful once about 80 percent or more
of the vehicles gain the ability to
communicate automatically with each
other highway capacity rises even more
sharply by compressing that traffic
allowing a smaller following distance so
in short by using robotic sensors in
communication to pack those moving cars
together more efficiently we could
eventually double or triple the capacity
of our existing roads as population
expands this would save countries
billions on unneeded Road expansion and
keep land available for farming housing
wildlife and other purposes but with
robotic vehicles the opportunities go
far beyond traffic lights or compressing
traffic stop and go traffic of all kinds
is the worst for mileage for two reasons
first if you're stopped you want to go
in anywhere right gas mileage is zero
miles per hour second when you
accelerate you use more gas than you do
when you can simply cruise at a constant
velocity if the transportation network
is tracking all the vehicles on the
roads and pedestrian traffic as well
that information could be used to
calculate and send electronic signals to
each vehicle about optimum speed and
position to minimize the time the
traffic on average is stopped congestion
levels that currently bring traffic to a
stop could be managed more efficiently
so that traffic keeps moving the tree
in two autonomous cars and intelligent
transportation systems will take time
but the technology is already available
to make robotic cars not only feasible
but safer and more efficient an
improvement that will probably be
rewarded with reduced insurance costs
robotic cars may overcome the trade-off
of safety versus speed as the
infrastructure for robotic cars to
communicate with each other through
intelligent network continues to develop
it's even possible that some roadways
will be restricted to robotic cars only
offering passage that's fast and safe in
any case robotic vehicles will continue
to make driving safer more efficient and
yes for those who want it even faster
than ever before